[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur le
plateau de france 3 pour ce débat ce
soir on vous emmène dans la nièvre dans
la première circonscription celle qui
longe la loire un territoire qui va de
conan aux verts en passant par la
charité près de cent dix mille habitants
dans cette circonscription la députée
sortante modem perrine goulet se
représente pour un nouveau mandat et
pour la première fois depuis 1958 il n'y
aura pas de candidat socialiste un coup
de tonnerre au pays de françois
mitterrand et pierre bérégovoy est à mes
côtés ce soir pour ce débat jean mathia
jolie du journal du centre bonsoir jean
mathias bonsoir cinq candidats sont
invités pour débattre avec nous autour
de ce plateau perrine goulet candidate
du modem pour la majorité présidentielle
le soir bonsoir françois le métayer vous
êtes candidat pour les républicains
bonsoir bonsoir léo coûté l'ex candidat
donald de la nouvelle union populaire
écologique et sociale investi par la
france soumise bonsoir bonsoir
thomas perret vous êtes candidat
suppléant de pauline vignerons pour le
rassemblement national bonsoir bonjour
et enfin or ni mbengué candidat divers
gauche bonsoir d'accord voilà il pour
être complet j'ajoute qu'il y à quatre
autres candidats déclarés dans cette
circonscription brighton verdès pour
reconquête geneviève lemoine pour lutte
ouvrière charles-henri gallois pour
l'union pour la france et michel peters
candidat sans étiquette
alors on va parler tout au long de ce
débat de votre territoire un territoire
rural de ses nombreuses problématiques
problématique la santé la
désertification la mobilité par exemple
mais avant cela une question d'actualité
un nouveau gouvernement nommé avec à sa
tête une femme elisabeth bornes une
nouvelle équipe avec trois priorités
l'écologie la santé et l'éducation les
eaux cotelec est ce que c'est un bon
message envoyé par emmanuel macron son
gouvernement moi je crois que c'est pas
un nouveau gouvernement c'est d'abord un
remaniement ministériel puisqu'il ya un
certain nombre le coeur des ministres de
l'ue de macron un sens dans mac row 2 et
puis on peut dire que non le message il
est pas bon le message elizabeth anne
borgne première ministre c'est le
message de la continuité d'une
maltraitance sociale et d'une
responsabilité écologique
faut se rappeler il ya déjà un bilan
elisabeth bornes ministre du travail
ministre de l'écologie un ministre du
travail et des à bedford c'est
l'assurance chômage un million de
chômeurs qu'ils ont eu leurs droits
diminué elisabeth board ministre de
l'écologie c'est 15% des effectifs du
mystère d'écologie en moins elisabeth
bande c'est la retraite à 65 ans
elisabeth bornes c'est la privatisation
de la sncf dans les impacts sont directs
dans la nièvre puisque la
restructuration liée à la privatisation
de la sncf ses quarante agents en moins
sur le pôle de nevers voilà donc non ce
n'est pas un message positif c'est le
message de la continuité d'une politique
de maltraitance sociales françois le
métayer pas de changement c'est ce que
dit léo côté l'expert je suis je suis
d'accord sur le fait que c'est un
gouvernement qui s'inscrit dans le
précédent essai mené pour autant je
crois qu'il ya un élément qui est
intéressant c'est de voir que on est sur
un gouvernement de clarification enfin
emmanuel macron a su mettre de gauche
elisabeth borne était dans le
gouvernement avec était conseillère de
ségolène royal était bien évidemment
halak et manuel macron qui lui-même
était sous françois hollande et quand on
voit surtout dans ce gouvernement c'est
la présence de papa ndiaye qui je crois
démontre l'absence de lignes directrices
pour notre pays vous avez un ministre de
l'éducation nationale qui va faire
complètement linverse de jean michel
blanquer air qui a fait pendant cinq ans
c'est la preuve que manuel macro n'a pas
de ligne depuis cinq ans qu'il en aura
pas dans les cinq prochaines années d'où
bien évidemment la nécessité d'avoir des
députés qui seront indépendants et
qu'ils ne vont pas voter nécessairement
toutes les lois qu'on va leur demander
or ni il ya plus de gauche dans ce
gouvernement alors dire que madame borne
est une femme de gauche contrée avant
tout fait une femme du système elle a
évolué en tant que personnalité à
l'origine de gauche mais après des
politiques qu'elles a menées on peut pas
être on ne peut pas le dire crette des
politiques de gauche comptait mener
cependant fait un nouveau gouvernement
qui vient d'être d'être d'être nous on
ne les jugera par rapport aux résultats
attendus les actes on attend les actes
mais par contre je me pose quand on dit
que c'est une politique de gauche qui
est un signe pour la gauche non pas du
tout elle fait partie de ces
personnalités qui ont évolué aussi avec
la gauche mais qui ont pris la décision
de 2,2 d'oeuvrer pour le système avec
les conséquences et les résultats qu'on
connaît aujourd'hui casse sociale
nos respects des engagements en matière
de l'écologie donc pour moi c'est la
continuité les mêmes causes produiront
les mêmes effets thomas perec comment
vous jugez ce nouveau gouvernement je me
souviens qu'en 2017 emmanuel macron nous
avait promis un nouveau monde avec une
alliance de ceux qui pourraient
redresser la france en réalité on est le
pire de la droite et le pire de la
gauche est aujourd'hui à l'occasion ce
nouveau gouvernement c'est une
continuité empire c'est l'alliance de la
technocratie macro nist avec elisabeth
bande qui une technocrate froide et
brutal qui comme l'a dit mon collègue à
gauche a été ministre du travail et a
mis en oeuvre la réforme de l'assurance
chômage il faut pas oublier aussi que
c'est madame bornes qui sur les plateaux
télé publiquement avait dit qu'elle
allait licencier les soignants qui
n'allait pas se faire vacciner ainsi que
tous les salariés celle sept ministres
qui disaient qu'ils applaudissent et
aussi le soir tous les soirs à 20h les
soignants pour leur héroïsme dans le
combat s'affairent aux copies 19
terry gou l'air elisabeth bornes qui
concentrent visiblement toutes les
critiques vous est-ce que ça bout
réjouit cette première ministre et est
ce que ce nouveau gouvernement c'est un
nouveau souffle pour le quinquennat en
tout cas visiblement il est bien placé
puisque on nous dit qu'il est de gauche
et de droite c'est qu'il est bien placé
il est au centre comme on veut le faire
depuis un petit moment moi je suis très
fier qu'ils admettent borne soit premier
ministre parce que c'est une femme parce
que justement elle est compétente elle
est compétente elle connaît ses dossiers
à les travailleuses et elle sait
négocier et ça je pense que c'est très
important j'aurais juste commencé par
enlever certaines choses qu'aux titres
qui sont fausses ce n'y a pas de
privatisation de la sncf fait une feinte
de mise au statut et yappa 40 emplois
supprimés la nièvre il ya quarante
emplois supprimés au dépôt de nevers
mais qui sont compensées par sans emploi
aux ateliers de nevers donc la personne
qui va perdre son travail à 9h45 du
dépôt vont migrer s'ils le souhaitent
vers les a tués et n'a rien à voir avec
le statut puisque c'est à l'inter de la
sncf il ya différents ateliers
différents dépôts et y glisse la charge
en fonction et donc c'est dans ce cadre
concernant le chômage moi je serais fier
la réforme pour la fête et je suis très
fier pour une chose parce qu'aujourd'hui
quand je passe dans les entreprises mais
moody's n'avait pas été assez loin est
ce qu'aujourd'hui il ya encore
même il ya quelques semaines fin avril y
avait 1000 postes vacants dans la nièvre
1000 les gens sont à la recherche de
personnel partout dans toutes les
entreprises où on passe et toutes les
entreprises où je passe nous disent le
chômage est encore trop avantageux on
est dans un moment de plein emploi donc
il faut que le chômage puisse s'adapter
en fonction des conditions quand on est
quasiment plein emploi bien le chômage
doit être plus restreint quand
effectivement dépend des difficultés le
chômage doit être plus long là on est
quasiment plein emploi afin à les voir
partout je pense que vous vous y allez
également vous de gens à l'ue sans
devoir les entreprises n'a pas une
entreprise qui dit qu'ils recherchent
personnes donc aujourd'hui on doit faire
le nécessaire pour que les entreprises
puissent recruter le personnel dont ils
ont besoin c'est important pour notre
croissance malgré tout certains des noms
des noms cela fait que ce sont des
emplois parfois plus précaires
sur les emplois précaires j'entends un
mais justement je suis allé consulter
les offres d'emploi qui avait dans la
nièvre quand on a un
une recherche d'une vendeuse dans un
magasin de téléphones à 1950 euros nets
on n'est quand même pas non plus au
niveau du smic quand on a une serveuse
dans un restaurant où on lui propose
2485 euros brut n'est pas non plus dans
le smic un couvreur à 2400 euros nets
un vendeur en boulangerie à 1750 euros
c'est les offres d'emploi qui
actuellement sur le site de pôle emploi
en y maintenant des emplois après
j'aimerais juste parce que vient de dire
madame roulé j'ai l'impression en
entendant parler que tout va bien on a
un nouveau gouvernement on a une
situation quand même en france qui est
qui est tendu socialement bon j'ai pas
je vais pas répéter la situation dans
lequel on se trouve et face à ça on a
quand même 71% des contres des 71 % des
français qui n'ont pas confiance au
gouvernement actuel pour répondre au
problème voilà la problématique par des
hommes du pouvoir d'achat et j'ai
l'impression dans votre interprétation
de la politique vous menez que tout va
bien on est au plein emploi
quand je vais sur le terrain le vert
quand je vais à imphy quand je vais dans
dans dans tous ces villes du département
où les gens souffrent vraiment on a
l'impression qu'il ya une déconnexion
totale entre votre réalité avoue et la
réalité du terrain
oui le problème n'est pas le plein
emploi en effet on approche du seau
plein emploi je m'en réjouis et bien
évidemment on ne peut que s'en réjouir
le problème c'est la valorisation du
travail et ce que nous devons avoir
c'est un travail qui est justement
valorisé vous citiez des exemples des
moules et c'est très bien et c'est
justement la preuve que les français qui
travaillent ne s'en sortent pas vous i
télé les salaires qui sont proposés nous
devons faire une véritable différence
entre ceux qui travaillent et ceux qui
ne veulent pas travailler c'est pour ça
que le travail doit être revalorisée
avec des baisses de charges sociales
avec baisse de la csg pour que le
pouvoir d'achat soit réelle et effective
dans notre pays c'est pour ça que nous
avons besoin de valoriser davantage le
travail il ne suffit pas simplement de
dire que l'emploi fonctionne en france
est une réalité ce qu'il faut c'est que
le travail paye est d'accord avec ce
qu'a dit
évidemment qui est un problème de
salaire et un problème de valorisation
salariale ça passera pas par une baisse
des cotisations sociales on a besoin
début des cotisations sociales ça
passera par une augmentation déjà des
minima sociaux une augmentation du smic
nous proposant un smic à 1500 euros nets
et les que nos négociations fait une
négociation sur toutes les échelles
salariale c'est pas vrai ce qui est dit
il n'y a pas de plaindre en france les
chiffres effectivement c'est pas sur des
cas particuliers qu'on peut voir moi
aussi je peux prendre des annonces et je
trouverai des salaires moins cher ça
c'est vraiment pas sérieux non il faut
regarder effectivement que le prix de la
baisse du chômage se fait au prix la
précarité ça c'est peu c'est prouvé et
céline c'est qui le montre dans la
nièvre pour les 16-29 ans le taux de
chômage est de 23 8% est-ce que ça on
peut se satisfaire de cette situation
dans la nièvre les jeunes
pour 40% d'entre eux ne poursuivent pas
leurs études supérieures pourquoi parce
que l'offre de formation est trop
éloignée
et parce qu'il ya de la précarité dans
les familles qui empêche le financement
je pense que ça les ajouts proposés ses
études à dijon où a clairement fait
qu'on s'intéresse s'il vous plaît avant
de dalé un petit peu plus loin sur le
fond les problématiques de vos
territoires qu'on s'intéresse un petit
peu aux enjeux politiques locaux dans
cette circonscription où la république
en marche et le rassemblement national
ont été au coude à coude à la
présidentielle la perrine boulaire on
vous a beaucoup entendu dire que c'était
dur ces dernières années qui avaient eu
des moments difficiles dans votre mandat
que vous viviez parfois même très mal le
fait que les députés de terrain soient
pas entendus pourquoi vous avez choisi
d'y retourner vous parce que en fait
j'ai rencontré pendant ces cinq ans les
nivernais les nivernaise et je suis
pétri d'une forte conviction c'est qu'on
a deux merveilleuses richesse dans ce
territoire mais que nous mêmes on n'y
croit pas forcément et moi je suis
convaincu qu'en des temps dans la
majorité avec le président république
qu'on a réussi à mener on a amené
beaucoup de choses en séries thouars et
si vous voulez on pourra le développer
juste après et je pense que faire partie
de la majorité c'est important bien sûr
on n'obtient pas tout ce qu'on veut et
n'importe lequel d'entre vous si pense
que juste d'être dans l'opposition va
permettre de faire tout ce qu'il veut
c'est faux c'est bien l'impression qu'on
s'est bien mal quand c'est bien mal
connaître ce qui est la vérité et
conviction conviction savez votre
conviction oui besoin j'ai remonté
contre les appels d'envoyer un jour on
est capable est dans la majorité tout en
ayant des convictions vous
je suis pas passé au modem pour ça en
fait quand je me suis engagé derrière le
président je me suis engagé derrière le
président comme ça peut arriver c'est
mon premier engagement politique et du
coup j'ai adhéré à un parti et puis je
me suis rendu compte que en gardant ma
fidélité auprès du président qui est
pour moi très importante
je me suis rapproché du modem qui porte
les sujets d'enfance de familles qui
sont plus proches de mes convictions qui
porte aussi la partie qui est sur level
l'évolution de la démocratie avec
notamment la proportionnelle à
l'assemblée nationale parce que moi j'ai
envie de pouvoir débattre avec les
candidats enfin les élus rassemble
nationale dans l'hémicycle et pas dans
les médias parce qu'aujourd'hui comme
ils ont pas groupe à l'assemblée
nationale le rassemblement national on
peut pas débattre avec moi ici et ça
c'est pratiquement 20 coups justement
les électeurs dans cette circonscription
où on a beaucoup voté marine le pen
quadrupler les votes les voix ont
quadruplé dans cette circonscription de
la nièvre depuis 15 ans comment vous
comptez faire et bien en expliquant ce
qu'on a fait parce qu'effectivement le
vote front national chez nous c'est pas
forcément le vote raciste comme on peut
le voir peut-être dans d'autres
départements nous les gens pensent
qu'ils ont été un peu oublié et c'est
vrai que pendant 40 ans la ruralité été
oublié maintenant si vous voulez
comprendre ce que de ce qu'on a fait
pour la réalité
il faut l'expliquer quand même aux gens
je pense que c'est intéressant et on
parlait de challans d'études on peut en
parler aussi on en rajoute énormément
d'études on a fait + 1000 étudiants dans
notre musée du souvenir sensiblement
délogés par des tout allait bien en fait
il ya des choses qui vont bien et
d'autres qui vont pas bien quand
tellement bien cette immensité un peu
madame vous voulez si je vous entends
tout sa renaissance vous des regards ise
vous vantez du bilan croyances je suis
madrilien wilber cela n'a jamais
souhaité le prix d'entrée est
aujourd'hui mais c'est le cadet risation
à outrance moi me sidère un peu et je
pense que cette idée aussi nos
compatriotes qui vous écoutent et qui
vont vous regarder parce que pendant
cinq ans rien n'a changé notamment pour
les territoires ruraux pour la nièvre et
c'est votre adhésion à la vision non non
j'ai la réalité madame si aujourd'hui
les prix de l'inflation l'inflation
gallo jamais pris part invité sa machine
madame parce qu'ils sont les premiers à
en pâtir parce que pour aller au travail
madame les trajets domicile il n'habite
pas paris ils ont pas le rer b où l'on
cache batterie sur l'essence sont nés
d'un cran
vous avez je viens de le dire fait un
très bon score à la présidentielle dans
la nièvre est ce que ça va pas être un
peu plus compliqué pour des candidats
comme pauline vignerons vous représentez
sur ce plateau qui n'est pas élu et qui
n'est pas connue localement aussi mais
paul vigneron est connue elle s'est
présentée à plusieurs échéances
électorales pas très connus
frais d'accord mais paul vigneron s'est
présenté à plusieurs échéances
électorales n'est municipal évidemment à
nevers en 2020 au départemental et même
régionales l'année dernière également
aux élections législatives en 2010 est
donc elle a un ancrage territorial est
elle mise aussi sur un programme qui est
un programme de bon sens après un crédit
pour penser notre en quelque sorte
encore qu'il est connu du score de
marine le pen
faisait petits seins tout dépend tout
dépendra de la mobilisation il est faux
de dire que l'élection présentielle et
la même collection initiative le tout
c'est de mobiliser tous ceux qui qui ont
voté durant cette action drainante il de
dire que la bataille n'est pas finie
qu'il ya effectivement un troisième tour
et que vous avez l'occasion de pouvoir
changer partie des dix et on sait que
vous avez un électorat
traditionnellement abstentionnistes ou
les jc wave mobiliser tellement mignon
n'est pas là aujourd'hui on peut que le
savez maintenant je vois pas non plus
monsieur
les présidentielles où les gens pas peur
de débats sur le fond et ben
moi je on a aussi et je tiens à le
souligner fait un très bon résultat dans
la première circonscription de la nièvre
et d'ailleurs si nous additionnons les
scores des forces que je représente
c'est à dire la nouvelle union populaire
écologique et sociale les socialistes
les communistes les insoumis et les
verts nous sommes en tête nous
contrairement à rassemblement national
nous voulons la majorité nous voulons
pas être une force d'opposition à poté
déclin nous voulons être majoritaire à
l'assemblée nationale et c'est possible
monsieur coûteux de pouvoir un mac rend
pas laisser le pouvoir à macron parce
que en fait on a le choix soit pendant
cinq ans à venir macron a les pleins
pouvoir avec une majorité présidentielle
soit on lui prend est ce que les
pouvoirs avec une majorité nul et c'est
possible mentaux a été beaucoup dit
mitterrand avait écrasé le pc
aujourd'hui pas de candidat ps dans
cette circonscription c'est quoi c'est
une revanche 30 ans plus tard bien sûr
que non c'est une victoire c'est une
victoire d'un coalition que toutes les
forces politiques voulaient et quitte
ici la ferme est bien d'accord elle a
été difficile parce que je qualifie cl
mais elle a été elle a été le résultat
d'une dynamique positif aux
présidentielles de la part de l'union
populaire qui s'est transformée dans une
coalition de toutes les gauches et de
l'écologie c'est ce que je peux en
parler petit qui fait qui a fait des
étincelles comme partout dans toutes les
circonscriptions il y avait mille 700
candidats qui étaient investis par les
forces politiques qui se sont retirés au
profit de la coalition à mathieu premier
fédéral ps de la nièvre jeu le site
parle de scandale l'accord n'a pas pris
en compte l'ancrage de cali la réalité
locale est ce que je remercie sylvain
mathieu de s'être retiré au profit de la
candidate de france insoumis sur la 2e
circonscription
ça a grincé des dents manquantes et ils
sont maintenant tous derrière nous
suivent à mathieu pas encore les prix
ils font campagne avec moi j'ai le
soutien du sénateur de la nièvre j'ai le
soutien du président du conseil
départemental de l'ancien président du
cade du conseil départemental
j'ai le soutien du parti communiste du
parti socialise de la fédération du
parti socialiste j'ai le soutien des
verts il n'y a plus de débat je suis le
candidat de la gauche et de l'écologie
sur la première circonscription est en
marche tous dans le même sens pour
gagner cette série
vous êtes sans éthique fondée des
valeurs de la gauche pourquoi vous
n'êtes pas derrière leo coûter très très
bonne question j'attendais de pouvoir y
répondre depuis depuis tout à l'heure
monsieur cotelec vous venez de vous êtes
en train de d'utiliser les mêmes
méthodes que vous décriez autrefois sous
prétexte d'avoir négocié à paris en
regardant la nièvre uniquement comme des
pourcentages vous avez fait des
additions rudare fait vadition que vous
êtes en train de brandir il ya des
personnes ya une réalité il ya un
terrain une histoire et à lanières et je
pense que les je pense que beaucoup de
gens moi je suis sur le terrain je suis
j'ai grandi ici j'ai grandi donc je
connais quand je vais faire ma ma
campagne c'est des gens avec qui j'étais
en courses déjantées fait des
professeurs donc qui sont totalement
outré par le manque de prise en
considération de l'ancrage local pour
ces élections donc quand vous dites que
tony séparer encore dit monsieur coûté
mais que tout le monde est derrière vous
que les présidents peut-être aujourd'hui
c'est pas eux qui vont aller voter fait
les militants et les sympathisants
socialistes et moins quand je suis sur
le terrain ils ne diront jamais je vais
répondre la plupart une rochelle qui se
démarque de la candidature de léo pas la
première chose il ya deux choses qui me
démarque pour être bien précis la
première chose c'est que si je ne suis
pas élu député ou s'écoutait ce n'est
pas de la lutte des le député je
continuerai mon combat dans la nièvre
déjà la première chose qui nous
distingue la deuxième c'est sur le fond
en matière d'europe en matière
de laïcité je ne partage pas du tout
certaines valeurs qui sont exprimés dans
ce parti d'extrême gauche donc moi je
suis pour une extrême je suis peau ça
c'est des discours des valeurs de gauche
qui soit républicaine
locale plus modérée les qui s'assume sur
des sujets sur place et plein de sujets
qu'elle a qualifiée mais pas jusqu'à
présent et je représente je pense une
bonne partie des vadais du peuple de
gauche qui n'a pas envie une fois de
plus d'être prêt d'être tourné en
bourrique dans cette histoire d'une
centaine de jeunes liverneuf dit
exactement où j'ai dit non ça fait
offrir maman c'est quoi ça c'était à la
base on fait réunies vraiment pour
échanger autour de la politique on était
vraiment autour de retours de ses idées
et au fur et à mesure ce que moi j'ai
fait en dire deux ans que je suis revenu
dans la nièvre que j'ai un parcours un
peu un peu interview à l'international
on a voulu recréer de 1t temps qui parle
de ces sujets là pour repenser la gauche
aujourd'hui voilà je pense que la gauche
n'est pas morte à l'est il ya une
tendance qui est laid fille qui sortait
par et les filles mais je pense
qu'aujourd'hui la nièvre quand
mitterrand le disais les nivernais ce ne
sont pas hypocrite et je pense que dans
ces élections là le peuple de gauche
rêvée pour push qu'il soit réveillé
l'intérêt et localement des 10 du bout
des lèvres c'est que vous n'habitez pas
été dijon vous travaillez à paris vous
êtes parachuté c'est comme ça que oui
alors dans le milieu autant est ce que
vous comprenez que ça puisse poser
problème peut-être à vous écouter les
électeurs comme des profils comme profit
de parachuter ont fait mieux elisabeth
bornes dans le calvados est parachuté
jean michel blanquer
moi je suis dit moi je suis pas mal joué
un parti politique c'est la première
fois que je me présentais une élection
je suis militant associatif du
département voisin
et je tends l'oreille effectivement en
tant qu'enseignant chercheur j'ai une
équipe très ancrée localement je suis
tenu par beaucoup de militants et
beaucoup de
la gauche la gauche de l'union populaire
écologique et sociale aujourd'hui elle
s'est mis d'accord sur un programme
partagé de 650 mesure qui compte c'est
le programme c'est le programme d'abord
et la réalité du territoire que je
connais bien et on va en parler et on
verra qui connaît bien les sujets ce
territoire alary enthousiasme à vivre
non parce que c'est compliqué quand on
n'habite pas c'est ça la question d'une
part j habite et d'une part je connais
bien j'ai dû à nevers depuis j'ai dit et
je me mets jamais habité à dijon
j'habite toujours en milieu rural donc
je connais bien le milieu rural je
connais bien les problématiques de la
ruralité je suis un spécialiste reconnu
des problématiques agricoles et
alimentaires qui je crois sont une
thématique important de la
circonscription je suis le porte parole
d'une coalition avec des représentants
locaux de tous les partis et croyez moi
que député de la première
circonscription daniel joret pas un
double discours vous serez j'aurais pas
j'aurais pas le discours de j'écoute les
nivernais quand je suis dans la nièvre
et je vote contre eux quand je suis à
paris je sauverai parole soumettons à
michel valache étages ne vaut pas
ancrage monsieur 300 invités je me
tourne vers vous c'est votre première
candidature première campagne après un
crash comme valérie pécresse l'a connu à
la présidentielle est ce que c'est pas
compliqué de se présenter ce que ça vous
n'avez pas découragé pas du tout au
contraire c'est le moment où nous devons
reconstruire notre famille politique à
travers les territoires les territoires
qui ont été oubliés depuis cinq ans par
emmanuel macron qui ont été clairement
méprisés nous avons face à nous des
députés sortants qui n'ont fait que
voter des lois ou alors qu'il a tout
simplement dit de voter tel pour ou
contre à chaque fois sans s'intéresser
aux haut territoire ce que je reproche à
madame boulet dans son bilan c'est
justement qu'elle n'a pas eu l'intérêt
de penser à la nièvre et c'est pour ça
que ma famille politique oui mais
justement la femme il s'agit bien la
famille politique que j'incarne c'est
une famille qui est temps que tu crées
la preuve en est c'est que j'ai bourg
nombre d'élus qui m'ont rejoint qui me
soutiennent qui est une une famille avec
des élus locaux et s'est séparé c'est ce
sénateur cfa pour être député oui mais
mal à
vous dire une chose si on avait une
france qui était l'homme et écouter
tout à fait mais sauf que si vous aviez
de la considération pour les élus locaux
et pour les territoires c'est comme ça
qu'on construit la france parce que la
difficulté on sur le métier c'est quand
même un département où la droite échoue
depuis des années ce qui encore de
l'espace entre le rassembler
confessionnal la répu complètement je
crois que justement elle clairement la
possibilité d'offrir une nouvelle offre
politique dans ce département une autre
avec les territoires et c'est ce que je
porte pendant cette campagne je le dis
très clairement si nous ne construisons
la france de demain à partir des
territoires plutôt qu'avoir un
centralisme parisien qui a été
parfaitement incarné madame boulet vous
avez raison par votre majorité nous
devons construire avec les élus locaux
avec les acteurs du terrain avec tout
simplement ce qu'ils sont face aux
réalités quotidiennes des français et le
jour où nous valoriserons les
territoires notre pays ira dans le bon
sens plutôt qu un centralisme parisien
dogmatisme paris sia qui écrase notre
jeu vous voilà vd eu aussi un terrain de
boules est pris non parce que ville a
bien appris sa leçon mais en fait il y a
rien derrière c'est que des paroles qu
est ce qu a que de concret moi je peux
vous dire qu'on la région dans la nuit
alors je peux vous parler qu'on dirait
concrètement dans la nièvre je n'ai pas
coupé donc si vous respectez je pense
que les gens attendent du respect dans
les débats à ce que s'ils entendent pas
ce qu'on dit ça sert à rien tout comme
et comptons sur moi je ne mets de la
conviction s'est pas coupé la parole aux
gens la cohésion c'est respecter les
gens aient respecté je ne partage pas ce
que vous faites mais je vous respecte
moi ce serait bien de mots c'est mieux
quand on dit qu'on a abandonné les
territoires ruraux c'est pas vrai on à
l'agenda rural qui a été mis en place il
ya deux ans il ya déjà les premières
marques qui sont présentes les maisons
france service le campus connecter le
déploiement de la 5g il ya énormément de
choses qui sont bien sûr tout n'est pas
pas n'est pas parfait c'est parce que je
dis sinon je serais pas sur un deuxième
mandat mais quand vous dites que
j'écoute dans mon territoire et que je
vote autrement mais c'est pas parce que
j'écoute et quand j'écoute j'écoute des
gens qui sont par exemple de gauche des
gens qui sont de droite et après je fais
mon choix on avait quand même pas qu'on
l'apprécié ou du mobilier commandées et
non uniquement et je voudrais juste
terminée sur une chose si vous regardez
mes votes contre un second vous indiquer
ma contrairement à ce que vous indiquez
je n'ai pas toujours voté comme la
majorité l'a demandé que ce soit
notamment sur les apl que ce soit suite
that le glyphosate sa a obtenu que le
courage mais je vais
j'étais coup j'ai voté contre oui chez
vous
je pense que c'est également deux du
crédit d'impôt que voulait total que
certains de la majorité ou leurs données
pour la mettre que je n'ai pas donné
j'ai pas voté pour et quand on parle du
centralisme parisien moi je veux aussi
les dégâts les dégâts de certaines
politiques locales quand on voit la
protection de l'enfance qui est gérée de
manière différente d'un territoire à
l'autre oui je veux que la pression de
l'enfant soient nationalisées et oui je
veux qu'on l'enlève aux collectivités
mère est en état de travailler avec
l'eau un roman parce qu'aujourd'hui
c'est pas normal que d'un territoire à
l'autre les enfants ne soient pas
traitées par la paix ça que ces
dernières une glaise qui les voyaient là
d'un depuis quelques minutes on
s'invective et on se lance des anathèmes
mais on n'avance pas sur le fond et là
on est à l'aube d'une crise économique
et sociale sans précédent et ce
qu'attendent nos compatriotes je le
crois sincèrement c'est des réponses et
des solutions concrètes sur le pouvoir
d'achat par exemple est typiquement là
quand on voit l'inflation qui augmente
considérablement et des gens qui
possiblement n'arriveront pas à finir la
fin du mois et en hiver prochain
arriveront n'arriveront pas à se
chauffer correctement faute de politique
énergétique eh ben je crois qu'on se
doit d'apporter des réponses est
typiquement sur le pouvoir d'achat il y
à des mesures phares qu'on propose de
rassemblement national comme la baisse
de la tva de 20 à 5,5 pour cent sur
l'énergie le carburant et le film après
le gars sélectif et votre adversaire
dans cette élection et qui sait la
majorité présidentielle s'est tendu
parce c'est évidemment le en premier
lieu et manière emmanuel macron la
majorité présentielle et c'est je crois
la mâchoire c'est le choix qu'ont fait
les français de placer deux modèles qui
sont radicalement opposés et
antagonistes l'opinion d'un gangster
vous êtes invités n'a pas été au second
tour messieurs mettez à 400 mille voix
il ya trois blocs qui se sont détachés à
plus de 7 millions de voix donc
effectivement il ya trois blocs un
bloc-notes deux blocs un plan là répète
et le rassemblement des sorcières de ces
cellulaires de la nuque mais ça vous
fait pas peur c'est ça que vous dites le
front populaire qui n'a rien de
populaire non non rien de populaire non
non vous avez prises et 7 millions de
français qui ont voté non monsieur corps
quand vous faites par les ducs en fait
l'apologie de la haine anti-flic
candidate soutenue par des organisations
comme le matériel
a dit chez nous mais j'ai des réalités
et vont
continuer avec des questions flash
[Musique]
voilà des questions d'actualité
nationale et internationale la réponse
courte vous avez 10 secondes chacun
première question faut-il chasser les
voitures du centre ville pour des
raisons écologiques ou favoriser le
stationnement gratuit pour aider les
petits commerces comme ça a été fait à
nevers je me tourne vers vous les
écoutez dès qu il ya une réalité
effectivement en centre ville les
voitures moi y'en a mieux ça se passe
après il faut prendre la réalité de
chaque centre ville je crois que c'est
en concertation avec les habitants en
concertation avec les élus que ça doit
se passer moi mon maître mot c'est
d'abord la discussion sur des sujets
comme ça mais la règle ça doit être
effectivement moins de pollution par la
voiture 10 secondes chacun comme un père
et moi je ne veux pas d'une écologie
punitive je veux une et une écologie qui
se fait avec et en concertation avec nos
compatriotes évidemment pour la voiture
il faut permettre à ceux qui travaillent
le plus loin qui habitent loin de leur
travail de permettre de prendre la
voiture avec en baissant notamment la
tva sur les carburants tel goulet je
suis convaincu que ce qui est fait à
nevers est la bonne solution le
stationnement en zone bleue pas trop
loin des commerces et une voie piétonne
tout le monde peut accéder assez
facilement à proximité du centre ville
et après peut marcher donc je pense que
c'est la solution or ni m'bengué
environnement kombouaré moi je pense
qu'il faut que l'écologie ne soit pas
punitif donc il faut vraiment adapté il
faut que ce soit la concertation des
différentes parties prenantes pour
trouver la meilleure solution mais je
suis pas à biner à la dessus je suis
d'accord également il faut que ce soit
une écologie constructive et qui aille
dans le sens de la citation bien
évidemment les sons la marge de
manoeuvre aux élus locaux pour prendre
ses décisions deuxième question c'est
est le creuset de la fondre des la
fronde des gilets jaunes dans la nièvre
à les routes sont toujours limitée à 80
km/h pour réduire les accidents faut-il
revenir à 90 km/heure perrine goulet
alors moi j'ai soutenu
des candidats qui se sont présentés pour
les départementales qui soutenait le
retour à 90 2 km heure oui la majorité
actuelle avait dit qu'elle le ferait
visiblement n'a pas envie de le faire
encore un engagement que la majorité
socialiste ne tient pas horning bien
entendu moi je suis pour le retour à 90
km/heure c'est clair qu'on
fera le métier
je suis vous aussi vous êtes tous
d'accord j'ai beaucoup terek je pense
qu'on n'est pas d'accord sur la raison
la raison c'est que en milieu rural les
gens sont de plus en plus contraints à
faire des trajets longs liées aux
carburants augmentent et aux alentours
de 2 euros si en plus aux alentours de 2
euros si en plus on leur met la
contrainte de 80 kilomètres heure c'est
la double peine donc je crois qu'il faut
prendre la réalité des longs trajets en
milieu rural où effectivement cela pose
problème d'être 95 sauver des vies ou
éviter de mécontentement thomas père est
évidemment le retour 90 km heure il faut
arrêter cette chasse aux automobilistes
qui pourrit la vie à leur vie et qui
contraint au quotidien leurs
déplacements inutilement alors avec la
guerre en ukraine on parle beaucoup d
énergie on parle beaucoup du nucléaire
on sait que la centrale de belleville
est tout proche de la nièvre est ce
qu'on continue le nucléaire où est-ce
qu'on stoppe cette énergie prend sur le
métier dix secondes chacun je suis pour
la souveraineté énergétique de notre
pays qui aujourd'hui passe par le
nucléaire nécessairement nous devons
continuer le nucléaire tout en
favorisant les énergies renouvelables
mais il ne s'agit pas de l'abandonner
tant que nous ne serons pas s'ouvre
terme après je suis absolument
favorables au développement de l'énergie
nucléaire parce que c'est une énergie
qui était carbonées a pu décarbonés qui
est très peu coûteuse en matière
électrique et qui produit énormément et
on doit lors des hivers il va falloir
sont passés à long terme combien temps
je peux pas vous le dire mais il va
falloir qu'on investisse massivement
dans un bisse énergétique dans les
énergies renouvelables la centrale de
belleville vient d'être recalé n'est
donc elle en prend pour 40 ans et 40
millions d'investissements 49 milliards
d'investissements sur la france pour
tours caréné il faut se poser la
question si ses 49 milliards on l'aimé
pas ailleurs merci nucléaire
je suis pareil pour le mix énergétique
il faut continuer puisque aujourd'hui
fin pas que ça aura un impact sur le
pouvoir d'achat c'est une énergie qui
permet de produire à moindre coût donc
il faut continuer mais en même temps
développer les énergies neurones goulet
oui c'est la seule énergie pilotable qui
émet moins de co2 que les autres et qui
sur une zone réduite et bien sûr
développer sillage les énergies
renouvables est en pente en parlant avec
les gens ce que les éoliennes dans la
nièvre au milieu des vignobles c'est pas
une solution alors depuis dix ans la
nièvre a perdu 5000 habitants quel est
votre mesures pour attirer les jeunes
une seule mesure 3 perret et ben on a
plusieurs mesures pour les jeunes est
également
l'une des l'une des grandes mesures
c'est de supprimer l'impôt sur le revenu
pour tous les moins de 30 ans mais
écoutez là qu'une mesure une allocation
à 1063 euros nets par mois pour tous les
étudiants et toutes les personnes en
formation ça permet aux étudiants et aux
jeunes de choisir leur voie et pourquoi
pas de rester dans la nièvre et de
bénéficier de l'offre de formation qui
est présente en soit la météo ils vont
avoir une véritable vision pour notre
territoire qui doit passer par le
numérique le numérique ce doit permettre
d'attirer une nouvelle population et
surtout de favoriser notre économie donc
je suis complètement engagé sur le
numérique perrine voulait une mesure
pour les jeunes rendre le territoire
attractif et leur donner envie de
revenir culture sport travail or nul
pareil je vais aller dans le même sens
du numérique aujourd'hui il ya avec la
transformation numérique il ya des
nouveaux métiers qui peuvent se faire en
télétravail je vais expérimente moi je
l'expérimenté moi-même pendant deux ans
donc aujourd'hui la lanière va toutes
les potentialités pour attirer ces gens
là donc attirant les avec le cadre de
vie qui va avec donc attirons ces jeunes
avec avec avec le numérique en leur
proposant des solutions clés en main
merci on passe maintenant à la troisième
partie de ce débat qui est plus
consacrée
aux territoires aux sujets concernant la
politique locale en premier lieu la
santé donc on va commencer par la
fermeture de la maternité de l'ovaire je
vous ai tout de suite ce qui n'est pas
une fermeture à la fin annoncée du
tampon l équipe à l a jamais été fermé
et ses pensées sur les urgences seules
les urgences étaient toujours été
assurée et les femmes ont toujours pu
accoucher dans la nuit viacom un
meilleur parce que ça fait peur après
aux professionnels qui veulent postuler
chez nous elle n'a jamais fermé elle est
éminent médecin qui avait des rendez
vous ne pouvez pas y aller sauf urgence
toutes les femmes qui avaient des rendez
vous avec les rendez vous était assurée
puisque les sages-femmes de journée qui
font les consultations étaient bien
présentes et n'était pas en maladie
c'était que les sages femmes qui sont en
salle de naissance les quatorze sages
femmes qui étaient en salle de naissance
qui était en arrêt maladie est resté pas
quand tu les gynécologues et la sage
femme cadre qui ont permis d'accueillir
les femmes qui souhaitaient accoucher à
nevers après en fonction si
l'accouchement était loin mais les women
est pas fermée j'aime pas j'ai pas les
pieds vocale mais il faut faire
attention dans les monts suspendus ont
dû faire appel à la réserve dans un
intérêt commun c'était pas un
fonctionnement qui est habitué à
faire et je pense que c'est important de
le dire alors je me tourne tempérait
donc pour commencer sur ce sujet comment
dissiper les inquiétudes y en a encore
d'ailleurs pour cet été l'inquiétude
principale de nos compatriotes courrier
en termes de santé c'est la
désertification médicale également l'été
dans la maternité oui mais cela fait
partie d'un ensemble qui s'appelle la
désertification médicale et on voit bien
qu'il faut la première chose à des
acquis qui est désertifier c'est
l'hôpital public il faut recruter
massivement des soignants 10000
notamment dans l'évier fait signer d'un
c'est une formation en soins infirmiers
il faut également revalorisée de 10% les
salaires d'aidés soignants il faut aussi
et je reviens sur tous les soignants
c'est ce que vous dites ont tous les
matins et je reviens sur ce que les
services bien sûr mais c'est une
nécessité et on voit qu'ils sont en
dessous de la moyenne européenne donc
s'il nécessité et je rebondisse sur ce
qu'a dit m tout à l'heure en parlant du
numérique ce métayer qui est avocat qui
est avocat qui nous regarde voilà et sur
le numérique je crois qu'il faut aussi
faire appel au développement de la
télémédecine des téléconsultations des
telle expertise pour désenclaver ces
territoires dans ce domaine là ça fait
20 ans que clamecy de 6 comme les
fermetures de maternités son chef qu'est
ce qu'on fait les eaux cotelec pour que
ça s'arrête ça très concrètes déjà dire
qu'il faut que ça s'arrête et notamment
sur les hôpitaux périphériques dire ça
suffit pas voilà il faut absolument
stopper l'hémorragie d'une situation
sanitaire catastrophique dans la nièvre
et se satisfaire d'un service de
maternité sur l'hôpital de nevers qui
marche grâce à la réserve sanitaire
c'est pas sérieux c'est pas sérieux les
femmes aujourd'hui dans notre
département vouera coucher à 60 70 km la
plupart du temps la maternité nevers n'a
pas absorbé avec la fermeture de
l'ensemble des maternités périphérique
n'a pas absorbé toutes les naissances du
département donc j'allais dire vous êtes
en train de dire que c'est un échec du
gouvernement s'est depuis cinq ans la
situation s'est dégradée il faut il faut
il faut prendre en compte cette réalité
la situation sanitaire des nivernais et
des libertés s'est dégradée en cinq ans
attendez je voudrais quand même dire une
chose c'est qu'il ya eu les clips ceux
du ségur on va en parler les clips du
ségur c'est bien c'est un coup
médiatique une prise de conscience du
président suite à la crise qu vide je
félicite mais le problème il n'est pas
conjoncturelle et structurelle dans
l'hôpital lorsque les dépenses de santé
ce que l'on donne pour les hôpitaux et
la santé en général et de 2% alors que
les besoins sont de 4 % et ça c'est
structurel et madame boulet a voté en
décembre 2021 la loi d'orientation sur
la sécurité sociale avec un budget de
2,3 pour cent alors qu'on sait pour 2022
alors qu'on sait que les besoins sont un
code pour cent structurellement on est
en train d'appauvrir l'hôpital pour me
payer ensuite faire une boulette avant
de rebondir là dessus je pense que au
delà des chiffres de tout ce qui vient
d'être évoqué
c'est une véritable vision de la santé
qu'il faut qu'il faut changer est ce
qu'aujourd'hui on doit encore
sur les thèmes des vies des personnes on
doit le manager comme si c'était une
entreprise moi je pense qu'il ya
vraiment un virage à prendre est-ce que
l'hôpital des services publics de
manière générale doivent être gérés
comme des entreprises ou est ce que
c'est quand même l'économie de la vie où
est ce qu'on ne fait pas justement ce
que ce grand virage qui fait qu' on ne
traite plus la santé la médecine comme
quelque chose concrètement comment on
fait là dans le cas de la maternité de
compression des cellules concrètement je
vais vous le dire ce que j'ai eu la
chance la semaine dernière de davos de
faire un rendez-vous avec avec des
internes il ya trois leviers le premier
levier fait au niveau et rage au niveau
du recrutement je pense que le constat
il est là il ya une crise de la vocation
que ce soit les infirmières donc voilà
avec tout ce qui s'est passé
dernièrement donc il va falloir recruter
massivement
deuxième chose fait fesser des métiers
particuliers où il ya un besoin de
formation est ce que me disent les
médecins on peut faire des choses qui
ont été faites par le gouvernement on
peut faire sauter le numerus clausus
mais derrière il va y avoir un effort de
formation et quand on regarde la moyenne
d'âge des médecins des jarres et
généralisé à peu près de soixante deux
ans les spécialistes et encore plus donc
quoi même si on fait le numerus clausus
il va y avoir structurellement d'un
problème dont il faut investir
massivement et faire le quoi qu'il en
soit la santé oms va laisser périr
goulet répandent la situation s'est
dégradée depuis cinq ans c'est ce que
vous a dit à quelques minutes et vous
coûter lac mais elle se dégrade depuis
20 ans situation n est pas la faute de
la république en marche ça c'est de la
nav ans et c'est les choix politiques
quand on supprime la gynécologie de
ville la spécialité jean écologique
ville il ya 20 ans ça amène quoi ça même
qu'on donne les compétences aux
sages-femmes les sages femmes peuvent
donc à l'exercer en ville à la place des
gynécologues on est passé de 20% de
sages-femmes en libéral il ya dix ans à
34% aujourd'hui pour ça qu'elles sont
plus dans les maternités sont libérales
fond de la gynécologie de ville
aujourd'hui on paye des choix politiques
faits il y a 20 ans et par les vols
internes que de caunes ce que 2010 elle
n'était pas allée pas fermer la
maternité de koné les suspendus et je
sens que c'est important
alors on va non mais
allez expliquer correctement parce que
enfin à un moment il faut aussi dire les
choses correctement la maternité de
caunes il y avait eu des injonctions de
les ré sultats des gros
dysfonctionnements on leur a demandé à
l'organisme privé qui s'occupait de la
maternité qui était kapa santé de faire
les investissements qui étaient
nécessaires dedans ils n'ont pas
souhaité les faire et donc on en est
arrivé c'est asus allons nous laisser à
une heure de voiture pour ça mais je dis
pas que c'est acceptable mais
aujourd'hui ce qu'ils disent est ce
qu'ils vont pouvoir par un coup de
baguette magique remettre des médecins
ils mentent
aujourd'hui quand on regarde le taux de
médecins parce qu'il faut le regarder en
deux années 2000 on avait dans la nièvre
137 médecin pour 100000 habitants et 112
aujourd'hui mais y compris à lyon dans
le territoire on en avait 150 5 dans le
territoire il ya en déjà nuit en 1 127
aujourd'hui si on prend les médecins
ailleurs c'est déshabiller pierre pour
habiller jacques et on le voit très bien
on a bordeaux qui craquent au niveau des
urgences dans la maternité de chinon qui
vient de fermer donc c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué que ce qui est prévu et moi
j'entends que c'est pas bien le numerus
clausus mais si on l'avait fait il ya
vingt ans quand vous étiez vovo vomir
vos têtes de liste et
quand l'on sait jouer mélenchon et quand
j'avais un peu les craintes non il était
comme dans un gouvernement il aurait pu
dire ça serait bien que son élève quand
même le numerus clausus puisque grâce à
sa mine de rien on a autre 2010 est
aujourd'hui on aura 2500 médecins à la
rentrée qui pourront avoir faim 2500
places de plus pour les médecins mais
effectivement c'est que dans dix ans sur
le métier vous avez pas travailler les
républicains ne sont pas assez travaillé
là sur la santé de non hélas les
décisions qui ont été prises qui en
effet on paie pas les bonnes jeune et je
crois que sur tout ce qui nous intéresse
c'est l'avenir quand on parle avec les
citoyens ni vers l'est notamment il skie
bien évidemment leur préoccupation c'est
d'avoir un problème au niveau des
médecins on pourrait parler aussi des
vous avez raison madame boulet alors moi
je pense qu'il faut avoir et ce sera ma
priorité en tant que député une loi
d'urgence pour lutter contre les déserts
médicaux avec un intérieur des mesures
d'urgence et des mesures d'avenir sur
les mesures d'avenir très rapidement
vous avez raison fin du numerus clausus
mais il faut que ça s'accompagne de plus
de moyens aujourd'hui on a une
difficulté majeure c'est qu'on met fin
au numéro plus on a moins d'enseignants
et on n'a surtout pas de moyens dans
l'université qui permettent de couvrir
cette nécessité de former plus d'un mois
et on a besoin de mesures d'urgence qui
est de mobiliser mais en concertation
avec les acteurs des internes de
médecine mais aussi des infirmières du
des pharmaciens on a un problème aussi
dans la nièvre dont on parle peu qui
porte sur les vétérinaires nous devons
aller chercher des ans des étudiants
pour les former sur le terrain voir une
formation pratique au contact des
professionnels et je pense que ça pourra
permettre à court terme parce que je là
dessus c'est une mesure d'urgence de
couvrir les besoins de la population
reste 10 minutes d'émission je vous
propose quand même qu'on parle de la
désertification a l'impression que ce
sentiment d'abandon de déclassement
d'éloignement du pouvoir il va de mal en
pis depuis 30 ans comment on fait pour
l'enrayer c'est quelque chose qu'on
entend beaucoup dans la nièvre bien sûr
bien sûr nous avons moi je suis le
candidat qui propose un avenir positif
et enthousiasmant pour l'univers n'est
les nivernais ça peut passer ça doit
passer par trois axes le premier c'est
le retour des services publics partout
sur le territoire pas un habitant à
moins de trente minutes d'un service
public parce que d'autres territoires il
ne sera pas attractif si on ferme des
postes si on ferme des gares si on ferme
des maternités si on ferme des stands de
périnatalité il faut absolument remettre
du service public partout donc ça c'est
le premier accident a été fait avec les
maisons france services s'est passé je
suis pas que rien n'a été fait mais la
situation militaire sanitaires restent
catastrophiques
il ya un nivernais sur deux qui se fait
hospitaliser en dehors du département
25% à 30% des nivernais qui n'ont pas de
médecin traitant donc la situation est
catastrophique
ça c'est le premier point le deuxième je
pense que c'est la relocalisation nous
devons créer de l'emploi nous avons eu
des désertifie dit nous avons eu des
désindustrialisation chronique dans ce
département depuis 40 ans il faut
stopper cette hémorragie là il faut re
localiser grâce à la bifurcation et la
logique raid pas la réalisation d'un an
grâce à la bifurcation écologique c'est
un million d'emplois qu'on peut créer en
france et je propose si je suis élue
députée qui soit fléchés sur des
territoires ruraux où on en a besoin
parce que la nièvre et le territoire
ruraux sans le creuset des emplois pour
la bifurcation écologiques de demain
mais en vain ses missions thema thomas
père est au rassemblement national pour
elle son sentiment d'abandon oui vous
avez raison de souligner le lac amance
en service public est à nos compatriotes
le ressentent des accords avec la france
a soumises en face à l'as bien je crois
que sur ce diagnostic là on est tous
d'accord je regrette que le bilan ces
cinq dernières années et est pittoresque
sur l'instauration de service public
donc on a parlé de la désertification
médicale mais on peut parler des
fermetures de classes 72 classes
nivernaise qui ont fermé en mai à
d'ouverte en échange non mais très peu
madame si très peu mais c'est une
évolution celle de 10 et ensuite sur le
lire la mention non mais on peut le dire
différentiel de fonctionner fermeture et
l'ouverture mais yahia mois 600 élèves
sur la fracture numérique pour aller
regarder la vérité sur la fracture
numérique ensuite on voit qu'il ya un
creuset 1 un gouffre à à combler et ça
passe par la couverture de tout le
territoire ni berné la première
circonscription plus particulièrement en
fibre optique est en haut débit ça passe
aussi par et là je vous rejoins un peu à
la revitalisation des centres bourgs et
par l'attractivité économique donc ça
veut dire construire des infrastructures
qui puisse attirer des entreprises des
services des commerces pour enrichir
l'activité économique de notre
département ce sentiment d'abandon il
existe perrine goulien quand même vous
avez été bousculée vous parlez gilet
jaune le rond-point de la charité sur
loire il y avait énormément de gens
c'est quelque chose qui existe comment
on arrête ce sentiment là déjà on
explique que tout n'est pas de la faute
de l'état parce que moi j'ai été très
surprise à ce moment là qu'on me
reproche le numérique le numérique c'est
une compétence chez nous par nièvre
numérique donc départementale ceux qui
ont fait le choix de prendre la fibre
donc à un moment il faut aussi expliquer
que les choix qui ont été faits n'ont
pas permis qu'on ait peut-être aussi
vite mais ses moyens c'est le
gouvernement qui a permis que sfr
viennent rajouter au pot et après
effectivement ces deux là qui a découlé
l'agenda rural et c'est là où on a
effectivement des dispositifs prêter met
en place je vois que vous voulez re
dynamiser sait déjà ce qu'on est en
train de faire et coeur de ville est
petite ville de demain ah bon quels
résultats bah c'est en cours enfin en
même temps quand on casse quelque chose
on me canton cas ce qu'elle joue si la
glace également baissé c'est simple on
dit quelque chose c'est bien il fallait
également c'est normal on vient de
lancer c'est qu'en 2000 café pour
redonner un petit peu de vie dans les
territoires au moment où on a un de
déployer deux qui sont en cours à ce que
le numérique peut être la solution tous
les tous les problèmes de service public
non pas du tout quand on connaît les
difficultés qu'on va voir je suis bien
d'accord et c'est bien pour ça que
effectivement les maisons françaises
nice on en a plus qu'une part pantin
puisqu'on en a 28 ans d'avoir 32
prochainement c'est également pour ça
qu'on a mis les conseillers numérique
alors qu'ils sont pilotés par
l'agglomération de nevers pour
l'agglomération de nevers est piloté par
département paul reste pour justement
aller contre cette fracture numérique
donc oui il ya encore des choses à faire
mais tout ce que vous proposez on a déjà
lancé en fait je veux bien sûr qu'il
choisit pas que c'est déjà fait mais
c'est ce qui est lancé moi je peux si
vous regardez l'agenda rural quand vous
voulez rajouter des formations on en a
rajouté le campus connectez vous les
ramenez une service public on à la
maison offrant services qui sont plongés
dit ces
mesures pour ramener dans la nièvre
c'est l'attractivité aujourd'hui un
territoire et pas attractif on l'a eue
pendant un mois j'ai eu une réunion la
semaine dernière avec les sages femmes
justement pour revenir sur les
sages-femmes et le département
l'agglomération de nevers et l'hôpital
et la rs puisqu'aujourd'hui les
étudiants on va pas les attirer comme ça
il faut les attirer sur le logement il
faut les attirer sur les conditions de
travail il faut les attirer également
sur l'accompagnement de la vie à
l'extérieur et donc c'est tout ce qui
est en train de mettre en place on vient
d'avoir le nouvel internat une crèche
est en cours de réalisation donc on est
en train de fatigue a pas été fait
pendant 40 ans dans l'année ciment
d'abandon et de déclassement sentiment
d'abandon et de classement alors
j'aimerais juste rebondir sur la
question précédente par rapport à la
numérique et son impact dans le
département moi je pense que le
numérique peut être source à la fois
d'emploi à la fois de décloisonnement
quand on parle de 2,2 à part de dd de la
télémédecine etc donc je pense que c'est
vraiment un levier qu'on doit prendre en
considération par contre c'est pas
forcément facile quand on est âgé par
jacques ce moment
je voulais en venir là dessus j'ai eu
des ddd rendez vous avec avec rencontre
l'univers n'est aussi bien ceux qui
vivent dans les quartiers que ceux qui
vivent dans la dent dans les villages
des pulls des plus reclus il ya ce
problème de l'accès déjà le un numérique
et le tout numérique quand il s'agit de
de se débrouiller même pour quelqu'un
qui est pour les générations viendra
dire ça peut être compliqué et ça creuse
encore le fossé
ça creuse encore les inégalités donc moi
je suis pour vraiment
qui est plus d'accompagnants de faire ce
qu'on appelle du excusez moi du terme
duffy j call de mettre de l'humain et du
numérique d'avoir le bon mix
entre la potentialité du numérique et
quand même gardé de l'humain et je pense
que ce jeu et je pense et je pense que
fait sur les français commencent à et
les conseillers numérique c'est
exactement ce que j'ai pas dis que c'est
nécessaire c'est peut-être pas suffisant
sur le temps de parole s'il vous plaît
c'est bientôt la fin de saison mais je
crois qu'à pas venir grise et une maison
france service s et du ripolinage de
façade comme dirait l'autre qu'est-ce
qu'elles ont été mais en remplacement
des msc ap qu'étaient les médisants
services au prix du public qui
n'apportait aucun résultat déjà au
préalable donc un moment donné il faut
aussi à braser politique ambitieuse et
volontariste quand installé dans le
quartier de la grande pâture à nevers et
d'aller dans le quartier des courlis
anneau vert qui sont en train et d'avoir
une maison services qu'ils en avaient
pas avant et que l'écart est énorme en
télé mais ça en fait partie oui là je
souhaite que les gens et la charité ça
c'est politique de l'asile et son public
va en avoir une et on a mis une maison
de samson public mobile à partir de la
charité pour aller justement dans la
ruralité et perdureront l'adapa l'a déjà
près des gens ont pas cru utile de la
ville on parle de ruralité ou les deux
enfin y'a pas de désinvestir de l'oubli
qui en a autant dans les quartiers que
dans et dans l'eure ruralité et
justement c'est là la différence c'est
que la circonscription il faut traiter
de la grande ruralité à la politique de
la ville et donc il faut pas sur l'essai
sur votre écran vous avez un peu de
rivalité après l'inquiétant je crois
qu'il faut qu'on pense à les opposer je
crois qu'il faut commencer par rétablir
un équilibre républicain une égalité
républicaine entre les personnes qui
vivent en ville et les personnes qui
vivent en milieu rural la dotation
globale de fonctionnement pour un rural
est inférieure à celle d'un urbain parce
qu'on pense à ce qu'on pense que un
rural n'a pas les même si tu relis ce
public oui je n'ai jamais les chiffres
parce que la dgf des connexions je sache
dernières années et 30 euros supérieur à
la moyenne dans sa peau c'est faux mais
vous les jeux les chips fait faux bond
ces 47 centimes la dotation c'est
l'association des communes de 86 euros
par habitant alors que au national à les
la finalité on ne mettra pas d'accord on
l'aura compris je vous propose d'en
arriver à la conclusion si vous voulez
chacun avoir trente secondes pour
conclure 30 secondes et pas une de plus
pour nous dire pourquoi les électeurs
doivent voter pour vous le 12 juin pour
vous donner la part nous avons procédé
je précise à un tirage au sort juste
avant cette émission et on va donc
commencer par vous perrine goulet je
souhaite continuer à être votre député
pour continuer à accompagner les
dossiers que nous avons entamé nous en
avons un peu parlé mais il faut aller
plus loin je souhaite poursuivre le
redressement de notre économie et je
pense qu'être dans la majorité
présentielle permet d'obtenir des choses
qu'on attendait depuis longtemps comme
unique optèrent sanitaire la première
année de médecine notamment et qu'il est
important pour pas que notre
département tant dans les extrêmes que
le vote soit sur ma personne et que moi
en tous les cas comme d'habitude vous
verrez sur le terrain tous les jours de
l'année parce que je suis né je vis et
j'habite dans ce département auquel je
tiens fort et dont je connais les
potentialités il faut qu'on les
développeurs simpere moullec léon côté
là qu'ils avaient la parole
les 12 et le 19 juin les électeurs
auront le choix soit il donne les pleins
pouvoirs et emmanuel macron et à sa
politique de maltraitance sociale et
d'irresponsabilité écologique pour cinq
ans de plus soit il donne le pouvoir à
la nouvelle union populaire écologique
et sociale et à l'assemblée nationale
nous mettre en place un programme de
rupture pour le pouvoir populaire pour
l'emploi pour la vie furent questions
écologiques un sujet que je défendrai à
l'assemblée nationale et qui touche les
nivernaise et les divers n'est
directement c'est la lutte contre la
précarité alimentaire 8 millions de
français sont allés elles sont à led
sont à l'aide alimentaire aujourd'hui
c'est insupportable donc on peut tout
changer le 12 et le 19 juin c'est fini
corning ping et 30 secondes pour vous
alors chers nivernais donc j'ai grandi
dans ce département que j'adore et je
vous demande les 12 et 19 juin de porter
vos voix à une gauche républicaine
locales et européennes
j'aimerais que
tous ceux qui sont déçus ou qui pensent
que les extrêmes avec leur leur
programme qui
qui nous mèneront à rien puissent se
retrouver derrière une candidature la
seule candidate heures qu'ils soient pas
d'extrême et qui sont en opposition avec
la politique qui est menée depuis
maintenant plus de cinq ans par la
république en autarcie français le
métallier
les 12 et 19 juin mesdames messieurs je
vous propose de porter la voix des
territoires oubliés depuis cinq ans si
vous ne faites confiance je serai un
député d'actions de terrain et de
conviction jeune et engagé pour défendre
les priorités de notre territoire la
santé le pouvoir d'achat mais je pense
aussi à des lois comme le handicap la
protection de nos retraités nos
agriculteurs et aussi la valorisation du
bénévolat que je vous propose ensemble
c'est de construire demain notre
territoire et de défendre la nièvre
merci françois le métayer la parole et à
thomas père est pourtant mes chers amis
vous avez été 52 % dans l'ensemble de la
nièvre a voté pour le projet de marine
le pen à l'élection présentielle ah si
les 12 et 19 juin prochain vous avez le
pouvoir de faire en sorte que les
français soient respectés et soient
remis dans leur dignité vrai le pouvoir
que la liberté de la france et son
indépendance soit restaurée l'épaule le
pouvoir de médecins à l'impunité au
laxisme judiciaire et à la submersion
migratoire et pour cela vous devez vous
pouvez vous mobiliser et voter pour des
députés du rassemblement national merci
à tous les cinq redevenu participer à
cette émission je vous rappelle les
autres candidats déclarés brighton
verdès pour reconquête geneviève lemoine
pour lutte ouvrière charles-henri
gallois pour l'union de la france et
michel pétards ce candidat sans
étiquette est les élections législatives
dans la première circonscription de la
nièvre le dénouement ce sera le 12 et 19
juin prochains dans les yeux en
attendant vous pouvez retrouver ce débat
sur notre site internet bfc point france
3 point fr on aura bien sûr toutes les
informations aussi dans le journal du
centre merci jean maîtresse de m'avoir
accompagné merci et merci à vous et à
vous pour votre fidélité passé une très
belle soirée sur france 3 bientôt
remercie
[Musique]